when you first learned multiplication
many many many years ago you got exposed
to the idea that one times I shouldn't
use that symbol one times some number is
equal to that number again that and that
makes intuitive sense you're just losing
one of this thing is just going to be
that thing right over there and you
could view it as one when you're
thinking about regular multiplication or
scalar multiplication it has this
identity property so it has the identity
property of multiplication one times
some number is equal to that some number
again since we're now exploring matrices
and matrix multiplication the question
arises well is there some matrix that
has the same property for matrix
multiplication so to make that a little
bit more concrete is there some matrix I
and let me bold it as best as I can in
my handwriting is there some matrix I
that if I were to multiply it times any
other I think I over bolded that one but
I'll just go with it and if I were to
multiply it times any other matrix a
that the resulting product is going to
be is going to be matrix a again by the
standard conventions of matrix
multiplication and to make that a little
bit concrete let's just imagine let's
just take an example for a let's say
that our matrix a our matrix a let's go
three by three let's say it is one two
three four five six seven eight nine
what I encourage you to do is pause this
video and try to think about whether you
could construct some matrix a and first
think about even what the dimensions of
matrix I have to be in order to in order
to when you multiply the two this way
when you multiply I times a you get a
again so I'm assuming you've given a go
at it
so let's think this through so let's
throw matrix a down there so let's see
copy and paste and let's first think
about what the dimensions are going to
have to be well when I multiply my
matrix when I multiply my matrix I when
I multiply my
matrix I times a right over here I get a
again I get a again so I'm multiplying
something times a 3 by 3 3 by 3 matrix
and I'm getting another 3 by 3 matrix so
there's a few things that we know first
of all in order for this matrix
multiplication to even be defined this
matrix the identity matrix has to have
the same number of columns as a has rows
well we already see that a has 3 rows so
this character the identity matrix is
going to have to have 3 columns so it's
going to have to have 3 columns and we
also know we also know that the
dimensions of the product the rows the
rows of the product are defined by the
rows of the first matrix so this has to
be also a 3 by 3 and of course the
columns of the product are defined by
the columns of the second Matrix so let
me so this is what defines this these
middle two have to match and then the
rows of the first matrix to find the
rows of the product and then the columns
of the second Matrix define the columns
of the product so we know this has to be
a 3 by 3 matrix now what else do we need
do we know well we know what the product
needs to be it also needs to be 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 so let's think about it to get
this first entry right over here we're
going to have to multiply this row this
row times this column since you take the
dot product of it so I'm gonna have to
multiply something times 1 plus
something else times 4 plus something
else times 7 to get 1 well let's just
think about in the most I guess you
could say naive possible way what
happens if we just multiply 1 times this
1 to get 1 and then 0 times 4 and add to
it and then 0 times 7 I think that works
out this if we take this product this
entry right over here is going to be 1
times 1 1 times 1 plus 0
times four zero times four plus 0 times
7 plus 0 times 7 so that worked out
quite well but let's just make sure that
that still holds what happens when we
multiply this row x times this column
right or times this column to get this
entry right over here well it works out
it's 1 times 2 plus 0 2 times 5 plus 0
times 8 so it makes sense you get 2
again and same thing when you do it for
this third column 1 times 3 plus 0 times
6 plus 0 times 9 is going to be 3 now
what do we do in the second row let's
think about it a little bit well the
second row right over here is going to
determine what values we get over here
so for example to get this entry right
over there we're going to multiply this
row we're going to multiply this row
times this column times this column and
we want to have the 4 so one way to
think well we just want this middle
entry here so let's multiply 0 times 1
plus 1 times 4 plus 0 times 7 and then
we're going to get 4 and that works out
for this next that works out for this
next entry right over here 0 times 2
plus 1 times 5 plus 0 times 8 we get 5
and it'll work out the same for this
entry over there now for this last entry
for these for this bottom row right over
here of our product to do that we're
going to have to multiply this row times
these columns or take I guess you could
say the dot product so to get the 7 we
want to multiply this tie this row times
this column or take the dot product of
this row and that column so if we want
the 7 let's multiply 0 times the 1 plus
a 0 times the 4 plus a 1 times the 7 and
just like that you'll see that at works
that gives us a 7 for this entry it
gives us when you take the dot of this
and that it gives you an 8 for this
entry and you take the dot product of
that and that it gives you the 9 the 9
for that entry and so just like that we
have constructed a 3 by 3 identity
matrix so the 3 by 3 identity
matrix is equal to 1 0 0 0 1 0 and 0 0 1
and as you will see whenever you
construct an identity matrix if you're
constructing a 2 by 2 identity matrix so
I could say identity matrix 2 by 2 it's
going to have a very similar pattern
it's going to be 1 0 0 1 if you have a
if you have a a 4 by 4 identity matrix
it is going to be you could guess it 1 0
0 0 0 1 0 0 0 0 1 0 0 0 0 1 you
essentially just have ones down the
diagonal going from the top left to the
bottom right and what's neat about
identity matrices you multiply it times
any matrix and you're going to get that
matrix again now another thing I
encourage you to do is we've just shown
that I times a is equal to a but I'll
let you do this after this video what
about what about a times what about a
times I we've seen that matrix
multiplication the order matters so what
happens here if you take a times I do
you still get a